so this dude's name is Dylan page she's
really big on Tick Tock and he's very
popular I'm looking at like five seven
million 10 11 million views they're all
crushing it so watch this despite it
being one of the most viable videos of
the Year somehow no one could find out
the identity of this woman next to a
journalist called Bria Dale she has
officially been identified so okay now
this is not blurred in his Tick Tock
that has her age well race sex ethnicity
it has her address her City her it
doesn't have her exact address he
blanked that up but he had city state
ZIP code County that's not it and she's
30. says her full her full name and then
this is more identifying information
about her company this says who her
employer is yep and like their phone
number their address this woman didn't
do anything why are you trying to ruin
her life you little freak lives in a two
million dollar home in the neighborhood
this man show her house and said
her neighborhood what is wrong with you
dude